now as the regards these moments
themselves they are directly derived
from the notion of end in itself of the
being whose end is its own self for
sensibility expresses in general the
simple notion of organic reflection into
self or the universal fluidity of this
this notion irritability though
expresses organic elasticity the
capacity of the organism to react at the
same time that it is reflected into
itself the actualization which is
opposed to the initial quiescent being
within self an actualization in which
that abstract being for self is a being
for another reproduction however is the
action of this whole intro reflected
organism its activity as in itself an
end or as genus in which the individual
repels itself from itself and in the
procreative Act reproduces either it's
organic members or the whole individual
reproduction taken in the sense of self
preservation in general expresses the
formal notion of the organism or
Sensibility but it is strictly speaking
the real organic notion or the whole
which returns into itself either qua
individual by producing single parts of
itself or quad genus by bringing forth
individuals
Hegel has now introduced for us these
three moments as he's going to call them
where we might say functions of the
organic being organism sensibility
irritability and reproduction and these
are you might say central categories for
analysis of the science of his own time
that he is examining but not entirely
endorsing now here in paragraph 266 what
we see Hegel doing is framing these
three in terms of what should now be
fairly familiar motifs of Hegelian
dialectics so we're gonna see him
talking about you know the notion of
universal filete fluidity you know
repulsion of self himself in this
reproduction
you know behaving for self being being
for another all these these metaphysical
categories that doesn't mean that Hegel
is actually endorsing this we might say
grand schema as what is the basis for an
adequate natural science in terms of
natural science turn towards organisms
observing reason engaging in you know
biology what he is doing is trying to
call out what he thinks is actually
valuable in this approach but we're
going to see in the paragraphs that come
he's also going to say some of this
doesn't actually hold up so what does he
do in here and this paragraph he says in
regards moments these three moments
themselves they are directly derived
from the notion of what the notion of
organism that we've been exploring so
far and we've seen that if we don't get
the notion right but rely on what he'll
is calling picture thinking we're not
going to be able to fully grasp
what's going on with with organism and
he thinks that at times observing reason
he has actually done it so what's the
notion the notion is of an end in itself
not the conch and end in itself that you
might be thinking of when you hear about
that from you know the second critique
or though the groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals here we're talking
about organism per se as being the kind
of being that is an end in itself we saw
that already discussed in some of the
earlier paragraphs or as we could say a
being whose end whose tell us whose goal
is continuing and perhaps even
augmenting or causing to flourish its
own self its own being to continue in
existence as an organic being not just
as a static thing but as something that
has life and it has these three
functions so he says these are the
moments let's take a look at each of
these moments now
so he says sensibility expresses a
simple notion the organic reflection
into self and then he gives us a gloss
on this saying well that's the universal
fluidity of the notion now when we think
about its sensibility think about your
your capacity to sense things seeing
hearing smelling tasting you know the
various senses that we all associate it
to one big miscellaneous category called
touch which include everything from you
know touching things to feeling pressure
to feeling pain you know a bunch of
different things right now it's
sensibility as he's saying it is an
organic reflection in itself what Sammy
it means that sensibility is the
organism able to take in what's outside
of it and make it an object for itself
it is aware of externalities
some of them maybe you know whether
they're right up against it like when
you taste something right but some of it
in other ways that are acting at a
distance you know for us humans we tend
to think of sight and hearing that way
but for other animals it can be
vibration or sensing heat or even odor
think about the function that odor
plays for so many other things on like
us who have lost most of our sense of
smell so what is going on there we this
is a function of organic beings why is
he talking about the universal fluidity
because it's sensibility or sensitivity
is not fluid enough it can't take in
that whole range of stuff out there that
we can then experience you know
Aristotle says in a certain way the soul
becomes all things and we don't want to
get in too deep into the data my you
know abstraction and stuff like that but
Aristotle also thought that the you know
the soul psyche that the animate
principle within the body was able to
take in information from the outside
through the senses and so that is part
of what's going on there the the
sensibility has to be able to adapt
itself to bring in to itself other
things we might have different
metaphysics you know explaining
precisely how this this happens there's
many of them available you know we have
some interesting ones proposed just by
modern science today there's no doubt
better than what Hegel had in his own
time but the key issue remains the same
how is the organic being able to not
just engage in stimulus response but to
grasp things outside of itself
as things to perceive them so there's a
lot of it all there you can see what
about a irritability
he says irritability expresses organic
elasticity well that's different than
just this organic flutie elasticity a
capacity to to give and come back and
respond the capacity to react a capacity
to react he says that is at the same
time reflected into itself the
actualization that is opposed to the
initial quiescent being with itself an
actualization in which that abstract be
able for self is for another this is
another key aspect of organic beings
it's not just that they perceive their
environment and grasp things within
their environment as distinct things
they also at least animal you know
animal life are going to react them even
plants are reacting in certain ways
although you know very slowly largely
through through the function of
reproduction for growth so but again
doubles that you have a nervous system
of sorts and there are many different
kinds just fascinating stuff when you
start looking into how spiders work and
and how they differ from insects and
arachnids in general differ from that
and then you know how vertebrates how
things go on them just fascinating stuff
Hegel is going to talk about this in
terms of the muscular system as well but
there is a key function of living beings
and then finally we get to reproduction
here who talks about reproduction the is
being the action of the whole or entire
intro reflected organism and he says
it's activity as in itself an end or as
as genus involves self repulsion the
individual he says repels itself
so this is you know we've seen this
movement carried out in Hegelian
dialectics the same is repulsive to
itself generates its other itself yeah
what do we have there well we have
reproduction in which we you know little
hamsters make more new little hamsters
that are different little hamsters but
out of the same on the same genus and
you could say the end there is a
continuing not merely of the individual
being because it is not actually the
individual being of such that has
continued it is a continuance of a
similar kind of genus right in
individuals so he says there we go in
the prorated accurate reproduces either
it's organic members or the whole
individual then he says reproduction
taken in the sense of self-preservation
so what are we talking about the
self-preservation continuing in our own
being that he says expresses a formal
notion of the organism or sensibility
but it is strictly speaking the real
organic notion of the whole which
returns into itself either as an
individual by producing single parts of
itself no reproduction of self as self
or quad genus bringing forth other
individuals new individuals which then
take the place of the individual that's
left behind perhaps on the spot as with
certain animals that die off when
they're younger created some of them die
off actually actually after they've made
it or you know maybe later in time like
us after we're able to pass on something
more an education a building a culture
to our progeny now this is what Hegel
makes of these three key moments here in
terms of his own metaphysics
the other significance of these organic
elements that is as outer is their
particular shape according to which they
are present is outwardly actual but at
the same time universal parts or organic
systems sensibility let us say as a
nervous system irritability as a
muscular system reproduction as a
visceral system for the preservation of
the individual and the species
in the previous paragraph Hinkel was
talking about the inner of these
different moments of sensibility
irritability of reproduction now in 267
he is being talked about the outer and
then he's going to bring these back
together in later paragraphs and he says
that there isn't other significance of
these organic elements that is the outer
and he says it lies in their particular
shape is how Miller is translating it
gestalt at the VISAA there you might say
their shape works for that and it does
convey that you know your salt but you
might say shaped kind shape twin shape
shaped modality right and what is this
consistent he says that their present is
outwardly actual as because something we
can observe that's what we're interested
in here but at the same time Universal
Hearts
is kind of an interesting things say
Universal parts or organic systems right
organic systems are part of a larger
whole which is the organism itself and
it's so he's suggesting one way in which
we can interpret this he is not
endorsing this again he's just saying
this is one way in which you can do that
you could think of sensibility as being
the function of the shape the organic
unity of the nervous system so that
would be the perceptual apparatus and
you know the nerves and perhaps you know
other stuff as well you're an ability he
says well think of that in terms of the
muscular system perhaps you know we also
want to include the skeletal system in
that as well it's what you need in order
to actually do anything
with the body right and then in
reproduction what Miller translating as
the visceral system the I'm giving which
we could just say is the the entrails
the guts you know the the organs in
general some of those organs would be
presumably the genital organs but you
would also include take for example the
gastrointestinal tract right because you
have to be able to in order to survive
in order to reproduce your being you
have to be able to devour things to eat
things that and then digest them derive
the nutrients from them and eliminate
the wastes so says this is a visceral
system not only for the preservation of
the species but also for the individual
so that would be one way in which we
could we could say that this is
externalize right not just for human
beings but for bugs and for mollusks
even for whatever else that we want to
look at
the laws peculiar to organisms
accordingly concern a relationship of
the organic moments in their twofold
significance one is being part of the
organic structure and again as being a
universal fluid determinist which
pervades all those systems thus in
formulating such a law a specific
sensibility for example would find its
expression qua moment to the whole
organism in a specifically formed
nervous system or it would also be
linked up with a specific reproduction
of the organic parts of the individual
or with the propagation of the whole and
so on both aspects of such a law can be
observed the outer in accordance with
its notion is being for another
sensibility for example has its
immediately actualized mode in the
system of sensibility and as a universal
property it is in its outer expressions
and objective existence as well the
aspect which is called the inner has its
own outer aspect which is distinct from
what is what in general is called the
outer
here in paragraph 268 Hangul is now
bringing together these two aspects
inner and outer that are you might say
correlative and essential to any organic
being which is what reason is attempting
to to make sense of attempting to
observe right and he's going to talk now
about laws proper or peculiar or
specific to organisms observing reason
wants to make sense out of organic
beings we've already done a lot of the
groundwork for that now an important
shift is going to take place so he says
that these laws proper to organisms have
to do with a relation they're trying to
articulate a relation and talk to her
about a doubled significance or the the
Miller text actually has a two-fold
significance but consult is the German
so doubled I think of this is splitting
we on the one hand the part of an
organic structure that is being
discussed on the other hand we have this
universal fluid determining this so if
we think about it in more specific terms
all right we have you know a part of the
organic structure namely the muscular
system that we just talked about in the
last paragraph corresponding to the
universal fluid determinate nasira's
ability these are both sides of the
organic being with just a set of organs
you don't have a fully organic being
Hegel would say there has to be this
universal fluid determinist this
capacity to to be more to transcend to
respond to the organs themselves on the
other hand you don't have something you
know ghostly soul floating around just
with faculties that is not already
connected with an organic system so we
have the outer and we have the inner but
Mohawk is supposed to tell us something
about the room
between them and now remember Hegel
already proposed to us and then started
you know peaking at one relation that
these have the namely that the outer is
the expression of the inner or the inner
expresses itself through the outer be
another way of saying it is he actually
going to bring them up here no and you
should probably ask yourself why he's
not reaffirming that at this point but
rather developing this further so he
says in formulating such a law for
example a specific sensibility would
find its expression quantal into the
whole organism on this side in a
specifically formed nervous system or it
would also be linked up if we're talking
about reproduction with a specific
reproduction of the organic parts of the
individual or the propagation of the
whole and so on now
Higgins going to tell us a little bit
more about this he says both aspects the
law can be observed it makes perfect
sense to say we can observe the outer
aspects because there Robert that are
observable that's part of kind of goes
goes without saying I'm certain this you
want to know how a certain organism
works well you can you know observe it
by looking at it you might dissect it
you might do x-rays there might be all
sorts of things that you do right he
says
the outer in accordance with its notion
is being for another so sensibility for
example has its immediately actualized
mode in the system of sensibility well
what does all that verbage the being for
another is the being for the observer
the external aspects of the organic
being organism are observable fine
enough so you know that the system is
sensibility you know you can dissect the
frog and look at it
eyeballs and how its nerves work and all
that other sort of interesting stuff or
perhaps gross you out stuff depending on
how you feel about dissection what about
this guy he doesn't he doesn't then say
that now on the other hand her relative
that the instead he says the aspect
which is called the inner has its own
outer aspect which is distinct from what
in general is called the other we saw
this discussed just earlier several
paragraphs ago
we're Hagel said in order for the inner
to be observed it must have a kind of
externality something by which we can
grasp it if it were just pure universal
fluid determinate nasaan the grasp of
our reason or understanding so here he's
setting something up that now in the
next paragraph we're going to look at
more closely
both aspects of an organic law would
thus no doubt be observable but not the
law connecting them an observation is
unable to perceive these laws not
because qua observation it is too
short-sighted and ought not to proceed
empirically but ought to start from the
idea for such laws if they were
something real must in fact actually
exist and therefore be observable but
rather because the conception of laws of
this kind proves they have no truth
you'll notice that I've done something
here that I almost never do which is
leave the same stuff on the chalkboard I
think I've only done that once before
throughout this entire series going back
through the previous 200 odd paragraphs
why did I do that well because he is
continuing the exact same line in this
this discussion in paragraph 269 he says
both aspects of an organic law with us
no doubt be observable so here is one
aspect here the outer and here is
another aspect here the inner observed
through its outer but then he says you
can't actually observe the law
connecting them now does that mean that
you can't cognize it at all or infrared
or anything like that no you are doing
that otherwise you wouldn't have a loss
over quit but you can't directly observe
the law itself
so he says observation is unable to
perceive these laws now why is that he
considers an interesting possibility one
possibility would be observing it's too
short-sighted and ought not to proceed
empirically but I want to start from the
idea to start from some sort of ideal
you know set of principles or something
like that Hegel doesn't endorse that for
you know as much as people like to say
ah Hegel you know he deduces everything
out of his ideas no that's that's the
opposite and he's actually saying that
you can't do that here in observing
reason he says such laws if they were
something real must in fact they
actually exist and therefore be
observable laws that would proceed from
the idea instead these suggests and here
we he's not going to tell us why that's
going to come in the paragraphs that
follow them but he's going to say the
conception of laws of this kind who's to
have no true
so what we've done in exploring this is
set up a a possibility only to knock it
down and you might say you know why
bother them doing when we're learning
something in the process and then the
paragraphs to come Hegel is going to
show us why laws like this I'm not
really going to work for us the way that
we hope that they do and when we're
watching observing reason carrying out
its many projects and trying to you know
formulate laws for organic beings